the Dominican Republic the first colony
of the Americas founded by Spain in 1492
today it's hosting the 27th ibero
American Summit a forum for leaders of
Latin America Spain Portugal and Andorra
22 countries in all
on the agenda climate change food
security migration and strategies for
regional integration to confront them
these leaders are supposed to make sure
that everyone can eat but if there's no
work no money how can people feed
themselves that's why so many people
leave our country
65 year old Luisa says unemployment is
made worse by the number of undocumented
workers who come here from neighboring
Haiti
presidents should unite have dialogue
and reach agreements so that we aren't
strung along to deal with the burden of
Haitian immigration because it's a
problem for all of us
also on the agenda is a new source of
inequality the lack of digital access
affecting more than 150 million Latin
Americans
there's no way in which any country in
this modern world with a digital
Revolution can really get into all the
opportunities for education for
production for employment good job good
jobs Etc if you don't have Broadband
broadly accessible
at Friday's a bureau American Business
Forum many investors especially from
Spain saw the problem as an opportunity
the point of these Summits is to agree
on common solutions to Global problems
very recently we suffered from enormous
wildfires and we received help from the
International Community especially from
abero America that demonstrates the
importance of our integration
but it's proving difficult the truth is
that this is not a very propitious Heim
for regional unity and
ideological differences as in the past
the red carpet may be out to welcome the
visiting dignitaries but the fact that
many of the leaders especially the two
presidents of the Region's largest
economies are not coming does not bode
well for ibero American cooperation
for those leaders domestic rather than
Regional matters are taking priority so
they will have no say here and yet
another thorny issue
disagreement on how to deal with attacks
against human rights in Nicaragua El
Salvador Cuba Peru and Venezuela which
are also proving divisive
yet another sign of troubled times in
the Americas
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Santo Domingo